[Music]
blah let's do it they've been waiting
for a second chance waiting for their
country to need them again yes meow you
guys give me if I kill that bird barber
that's a bald eagle get away Baldy guys
what do I win one-way ticket to hell
it turns out the French Canadian town
same George Jr raw is actually on
American soil
you'll be phasing out a Canadian Mountie
unit best behavior boy our idea of a
good time either fellas personally I'd
rather [ __ ] a moose you wouldn't need a
ladder to do that Wow let's give a big
Canadian welcome to the venmo hi wait
that's our guys they've come up here to
tell us how great it's gonna be for all
of us to become Americans
this is happening yes to who serve a
aquel Vitas was alleged in either of you
speak English I did we would like to eat
your paper can you show me your party
papers this time everything will be by
the book everything ghosts
we're gonna get for you guys whole beer
get Ricola what did you say do you want
a liter of Cola Canada's pretty awesome
don't do that
a grape or Maki decide to read the root
feather does their car so name is Rob
Liefeld catcher Luc Robitaille doubt
dannion pa Fran Tarkenton t-nut was
their process
[Music]